[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Keeping tabs on your
apps and dealing with errors
can involve multiple tools
from multiple vendors.
This is far from
ideal, and you really
want all the tools
you need in one place.
Stackdriver monitoring
provides visibility
into the performance,
uptime, and overall health
of cloud-powered applications.
Stackdriver collects
metrics, events, and metadata
from Google Cloud Platform,
Amazon Web Services,
posted uptime probes,
application instrumentation,
and a variety of common
application components,
including Cassandra,
Nginx, Apache Web Server,
and many others.
Stackdriver ingests
that data and generates
insights via dashboards,
charts, and alerts.
Stackdriver alerting
helps you collaborate
by integrating with
Slack, PagerDuty, HipChat,
Campfire, and more.
This hands-on lab shows you
how to monitor a Google Compute
Engine virtual machine
instance with Stackdriver.
You'll also install monitoring
and logging agents for your VM
which collects more information
from your instance, which
could include metrics and
logs from third-party apps.
By the end of the lab, you'll
have successfully monitored
a virtual machine and checked
the logs it generated.
Next up on our quest is Cloud
Functions, Qwik Start console.
[MUSIC PLAYING]